are you sure the olive oil you have
board comes from the region indicated on
the label or that the fish on your
plates is what you have ordered what
information helps you decide what to buy
food fraud is the violation of EU food
law with the intention to deceive
consumers for financial gain every year
food fraud costs between eight and
twelve billion euros in damages to the
industry it causes consumers to lose
trust in what they buy and harms the
reputation of honest businesses food
fraud may also pose a health risk to
consumers for instance when cheaper
allergenic ingredients substitute
expensive ones the knowledge center for
food fraud and quality investigates
these issues and helps to ensure food
authenticity and quality in the EU we
collect validate and disseminate
knowledge and make it available to EU
policymakers regulating the food feed
chain to competent authorities in
European countries and to citizens to do
this we create databases containing the
composition of food products such as
wine and honey
we set up networks of experts to collect
and disseminate knowledge we help to
introduce science into policymaking we
develop and harmonized analytical
methods to check product authenticity
and quality
find out more about the knowledge center
for food fraud and quality
[Music]